en 1991 la segunda mayor potencia
militar del planeta y uno de los
ejércitos más poderosos del mundo se
enfrentan a un futuro incierto miles de
hombres en edad militar con formación de
élite conocimiento avanzado las
terribles prácticas soviéticas son
fichados por empresas militares y
sobreviven como soldados de fortuna si
usted tiene algún problema el dinero
suficiente quizás pueda contratarlos el
equipo rusia
[Música]
querida comunidad de visual político no
penséis ni por un segundo que estamos
exagerando actualmente en nuestro mundo
hay decenas y decenas de empresas de
fuerzas militares que operan en
conflictos internacionales sobre todo en
áfrica son las llamadas empresas
militares y de seguridad privada y no
sólo de fuerzas de seguridad privada no
nos referimos a los guardias que podemos
encontrar en centros comerciales o en la
empresa del armadas que tengas
contratada hablamos de auténticas
organizaciones de soldados con formación
y equipamiento militar avanzado que son
contratadas por dinero pero queréis
saber más sobre el desconocido mundo de
los ejércitos privados pues arranquemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
antes de comenzar dejadme que os hable
de nuestro patrón
[Música]
i
si eres escritor de visual política y te
gusta lo que hacemos ahora puedes ayudar
vamos a seguir mejorando día a día
sumando té a nuestra comunidad en patrio
tienes cinco niveles diferentes para
elegir cada uno de ellos con distintos
beneficios exclusivos desde nuestro
conocido boletín las claves de la semana
a vídeos editoriales extra o regalos
exclusivos para patronos si queréis
echar un vistazo os dejamos el enlace
por aquí abajo en la descripción pero
dicho esto comenzemos y si os parece
podemos hacerlo con una pregunta son los
ejércitos privados un fenómeno único de
los países de europa del este pues no
desde luego que no porque amigos aunque
el equipo a fue una serie de ciencia
ficción el concepto subyacente es muy
pero que muy real mucho más de lo que
podríamos pensar a simple vista tanto en
el este como en el propio oeste aunque
por supuesto podemos encontrar algunas
diferencias
[Música]
el occidente también hay una importante
industria de empresas militares y de
seguridad privada sin embargo son un
tanto diferente es algo que podemos
encontrar por ejemplo en rusia de esta
forma mientras que este tipo de empresas
rusas siempre están habitualmente
servicios de combate las occidentales
que son fundamentalmente estadounidenses
se centran sobre todo en prestar apoyo
militar proteger infraestructuras claves
o incluidas por supuesto las
infraestructuras militares o encargarse
de realizar labores técnicas avanzadas
sin embargo por lo general lo que no
quiere decir siempre son reacias a
participar en combates directos
esto un momento un momento porque antes
de seguir por esta senda la pregunta que
podemos hacernos llegados hasta aquí es
visual político me estás hablando de
empresas militares privadas pero
realmente son este tipo de compañías
aceptadas por la comunidad internacional
pues bueno digamos que aquí tenemos que
hacer muchos matices
y es que veréis en el año 1989 y tras
hacerse públicas varias atrocidades
cometidas por cuerpos de mercenarios en
áfrica tuvo lugar la convención
internacional contra el reclutamiento la
utilización la financiación y el
entrenamiento de mercenarios
en esta convención impulsada por las
naciones unidas- buscaba prohibir tanto
a los mercenarios como también las
empresas privadas militares a las que
considera poco más que una evolución de
los primeros la idea era que para
finales del 2001 todos los países
evitarán recurrir a mercenarios y
empresas militares privadas sin embargo
hasta el día de hoy apenas 46 países la
han ratificado y por supuesto entre los
46 no están quienes más uso hacen de
estos servicios ni siquiera un país como
españa está en esa reducida lista
y si tal y como os podéis imaginar ni
eeuu ni rusia ni tampoco el reino unido-
que son los tres países que con mucha
diferencia más utilizan este tipo de
instrumentos están en la lista de
firmantes en con el caso la cuestión es
que hablamos de todo una enorme
industria que a nivel mundial mueve
entre 20.000 y 100.000 millones de
dólares anuales y que en ocasiones
obtiene contratos tan importantes como
estos en afganistán se gastaron más de
100.000 millones de dólares en
contratistas militares un informe de
bloomberg apunta que en abril de 2021
había 16 mil 832 trabajadores empleados
por contratistas militares privados en
afganistán siendo seis mil ciento
cuarenta y siete de ellos ciudadanos
estadounidenses en eso era más del doble
de los 2.500 soldados estadounidenses
que quedaban en ese momento pues si
puede resultarnos sorprendente pero
recurrir a unidades militares privadas
es mucho más común de lo que podríamos
pensar
empresas fundamentalmente de eeuu y
rusia que luego a su vez en muchos casos
subcontrata nos montan empresas locales
en el propio terreno de las operaciones
de esta forma si necesitas un cuerpo de
élite para proteger una instalación
sensible si necesitas un equipo que se
encargue de dar formación militar
avanzada si necesitas labores de
inteligencia localización de agentes
enemigos control de radar gestión de
misiles avanzados lo que sea tan solo
tienes que [ __ ] el teléfono y pedir
presupuesto bueno no es tan sencillo
pero ya me entendéis
[Música]
ahora bien porque hablamos de rusia cuál
es la diferencia la clave que hace que
la industria militar privada rusa suele
ir mucho pero que mucho más allá que la
norteamericana y quizás la pregunta más
importante de todas si tienes que
contratar una empresa de este tipo por
qué demonios rusia es una opción tan
popular pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
usando la línea
porque rusia se ha convertido en todo un
hub de empresas militares privadas para
responder a esta pregunta amigos tenemos
que echar la vista atrás la caída de la
unión soviética dejó a miles y miles de
militares sin trabajo
[Música]
tras el colapso de la urss el ejército
experimento una importante reducción en
el número de hombres porque había un
enorme excedente la unión soviética
había sido un estado en gran medida
militarizado mientras su caída y hacían
falta tantas unidades militares ni había
cómo pagarlas esto hizo que muchos
soldados e incluso también oficiales y
personal de mayor rango tuvieran que
buscarse la vida y cuando lo único que
sabes hacer tiene que ver con temas
militares pues blanco y en botella
convertirse en todo un soldado de
fortuna se convirtió en una opción
lógica
y eso no es todo el fin de la urss y la
caída de sus estructuras también provocó
un importante descontrol en la gestión
de los arsenales especialmente los que
quedaron fuera de la actual rusia
[Aplausos]
de esta forma por ejemplo muchos
helicópteros mi-17 y mi-24 fueron
abandonados y quedaron en manos de
oficiales y pilotos ex soviéticos que
optaron por darles una salida lucrativa
y sacar tajada y así de esta forma es
como los rusos se familiarizaron con la
industria internacional de las empresas
militares hasta el punto de convertirse
poco a poco en toda una superpotencia en
el campo ahora bien si vamos al terreno
práctico porque recurrir a este tipo de
empresas y no emplear a un ejército
convencional para qué demonios se usan
realmente este tipo de compañías
queridos amigos amigas esta es una
pregunta fundamental
[Música]
en el caso de las empresas
norteamericanas la respuesta más
aceptada es la eficiencia en algunos
aspectos estas empresas logran reducir
sustancialmente los costes de operación
de los ejércitos nacionales gracias a su
especialización en materias muy
concretas por ejemplo hay empresas
especializadas en la protección de
aeródromos militares otras en la
seguridad de perímetros en zonas
acotadas de guerra otras en el control
de checkpoints yo en algunos casos
incluso prestan servicios que muchos
ejércitos por sí mismo no están
preparados para realizar es algo que
vimos por ejemplo en afganistán la
retirada de estas empresas privadas e
hizo que la fuerza aérea afgana se
volviera prácticamente inoperativa
sin embargo en el caso de las empresas
rusas junto a estas operaciones
encontramos también muchas más razones
por ejemplo fijaos
sí ya sé que hemos hablado muchas veces
de los hombrecillos verdes de ucrania y
durante la invasión del este educan y
crimea muchos medios de comunicación
dijeron que eran soldados rusos y bueno
lo cierto es que sí y no al mismo tiempo
soldados rusos hubo en el terreno eso es
casi seguro y desde luego todos estaban
al servicio del kremlin pero lo más
probable es que muchas de esas unidades
que asaltaron el este de ucrania
formarán parte de empresas de servicios
militares contratadas por el propio
gobierno ruso por entornos cercanos a
este lo que quiere decir que sí que es
muy posible que vladimir putin no mienta
no al menos técnicamente cuando dice que
el ejército ruso no invadió ucrania lo
que como veis no quiere decir que rusia
no invadiera ucrania cuestión de matices
de esta forma las intenciones y el
resultado pueden ser los mismos aunque
en este caso nadie puede estar seguro al
cien por cien de la autoría nos tenemos
que conformar con un 99 por ciento pero
podéis creerme eso en la política
internacional es una diferencia enorme
rusia acumula un amplio bagaje en el uso
tanto de empresas militares privadas
como también de mercenarios en su
historial de conflictos militares en el
más sonado por ejemplo es el batallón
vostok formado por el señor de la guerra
que nos suelen llamado a jeff en 1999 al
comienzo de la segunda guerra chechena
más tarde este batallón participaría
también en la guerra de georgia entre
2007 y 2008 y más recientemente en
ucrania donde ha sido rebautizado en
algunos casos como el batallón bombas
la cuestión es que los métodos
utilizados por este batallón son tan
brutales que ni siquiera rusia acepta
abiertamente su relación con ellos el
gobierno ruso se conforma con decir que
bueno que se trata simplemente de
voluntarios locales que se suman a su
causa ya sabéis el altruismo llevado a
su quintaesencia todo por la madre
patria rusia lo que en realidad quiere
decir todo por los billetes del diosa
[Música]
el caso es que supuestamente este
batallón que hemos tomado como ejemplo
se disolvió en el año 2009 pero lo
cierto es que nunca lo hizo y cuando
llegó el 2014 y la crisis de ucrania que
mejor estrategia que recurrir a estos
mismos efectivos claro que no podía ser
tan obvio había que mejorar la
subcontrata
el gobierno ruso evitó que en el
batallón hubiera demasiadas unidades
ligadas a los conflictos de chechenia y
georgia de esta forma mientras que en el
corazón de la conocida comunidad del
tomba se estaba formado por mercenarios
chechenos experimentados en el grueso
del cuerpo lo integraban combatientes
separatistas de donets que habían sido
reclutados con anterioridad y por
supuesto no se trató únicamente de las
unidades de combate con los suministros
las armas y otras operaciones especiales
la operativa fue muy similar
y si así es exactamente como rusia
subcontrató la guerra a grupos de
mercenarios y empresas privadas
militares pero amigos amigas aquí no
termina todo la pregunta que podemos
hacernos ahora es pero qué ocurre con
todos estos grupos cuando no están
trabajando para el gobierno ruso y está
pasando y por hoy con esta industria
quién demonios son sus principales
actores pues bien atentos
[Música]
russia un macro hat de guerra privada
empecemos con una pregunta cuántas
empresas militares privadas creéis que
hay en rusia 1 2 3 quizás cinco pues no
se calcula que en total hablamos de
entre 10 y 20 empresas de este tipo
registradas registradas eso sí de formas
muy variopintas porque legales legales
como tal pues no lo son aunque el propio
gobierno sea un buen cliente en
cualquier caso la mayoría de ellas están
registradas como empresas de seguridad
convencional claro que de convencional
tienen muy pero que muy poco y como es
lógico y siempre ocurre unas destacan
más que otras y muchas de ellas están
especializadas en campos muy
determinados
[Música]
por ejemplo tenemos anti terror en una
empresa militar privada registrada como
un centro de educación y formación no
gubernamental en realidad la actividad
de la empresa es completamente diferente
antiterror on él se encarga por ejemplo
de proteger por cualquier medio ya gran
escala las operaciones de varias grandes
empresas rusas en países como irak u
otro ejemplo bastante conocido es more
and security una empresa militar
establecida por antiguos miembros de la
fsb es decir los servicios secretos
rusos y de la armada nacional
esta empresa more and security por
ejemplo afirma en su web que se dedica a
escoltar barcos y a recuperar barcos
secuestrados de hecho una de sus
operaciones más conocidas fue el rescate
de un barco de emiratos árabes unidos-
secuestrado en 1999 por sudaneses pero
eso eso no es todo
[Música]
también tienen un importante historial
de operaciones terrestres entre ellas
operaciones en zonas como irak y varios
países de áfrica y por cierto por si os
lo estáis preguntando si la empresa
cuenta con sus propios buques de asalto
los cuales tienen matrícula de las islas
cook y sus propios vehículos blindados y
bueno en cierta forma cualquier cosa que
necesiten para llevar a cabo sus
operaciones porque evidentemente el
gobierno ruso no es ni de lejos su único
cliente amigos amigas el peso de este
tipo de empresas en muchos de los
conflictos internacionales más
importantes que podemos encontrar en la
actualidad no es precisamente pequeño
pero volviendo a ucrania y a la
presencia de empresas militares privadas
en esta contienda quedaos con este
nombre rsb group esta es otra empresa
militar privada que fue registrada en el
año 2011 también por ex funcionarios del
csb ruso y del departamento central de
inteligencia más conocido como red
[Música]
y esta empresa además de llevar a cabo
numerosas operaciones de protección de
buques en aguas africanas de somalia y
el golfo de guinea operaciones de
eliminación de minas en libia también
parece estar vinculada con la invasión a
ucrania el sitio web ucraniano informa
pan afirma que recibe grupo colaboró con
los rebeldes respaldados por rusia en el
donbass y que asimismo esta empresa
participó en las operaciones de anexión
de crimea
para stewart y es como loco dos
observadores rusos del sector la rsb
group es la empresa militar privada más
compleja y quizás más similar a las que
podemos encontrar en occidente y en
especial por supuesto en eeuu por
ejemplo cuentan también con su propio
departamento de ciberdefensa e incluso
se dice que llegaron a rechazar un
encargo de un estado para influir en las
elecciones de un estado extranjero
cliente que según ellos no era rusia
[Música]
el caso para que veáis hasta dónde llega
la influencia de este tipo de compañías
es que en los últimos 12 años han sido
por lo menos 4 los intentos de realizar
cambios legislativos para legalizarlas
plenamente algo con lo que el propio
vladimir putin se ha mostrado de acuerdo
en alguna ocasión el problema es que
legalizarlas supondría en cierta forma
regularizar las y ponerlas bajo un
estricto control del psb el jefe o el
propio ministerio de defensa o
exteriores de rusia así que lo cierto es
que ni ellas mismas están de acuerdo su
estatus actual de la legalidad parece el
más conveniente de todos para todas las
partes incluido por supuesto el gobierno
ruso por ejemplo habéis oído hablar de
la guerra híbrida a expensas de lo bien
qué mejor forma de llevarla a cabo que
recurrir a este tipo de empresas ahora
bien la pregunta es qué te parece que tu
país recurra a este tipo de compañías te
parecería bien subcontratar una parte de
la seguridad nacional o de las
operaciones militares en el extranjero
de tu propio país déjanos tu respuesta
por aquí abajo en los comentarios y
recuerda si este vídeo te resultó
interesante no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visual política y si
además te gusta lo que hacemos hoy
échale un vistazo a nuestra comunidad de
pattern todo aportación al proyecto es
más que bienvenida en fin una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]